hello everyone and welcome to a most
exciting game from the Auriga feed a
grand prix 2019 and now as of this year
you all know that the Grand Prix has a
new elimination system they are having
the knockout system and first the
players will play to classical games
then to rapid games then two shorter
rapid games ten plus ten and then they
will play to blitz games and if all of
those games are drawn then they go into
the Armageddon where White has five
minutes Black has four minutes but if
the game is drawn then black wins the
matchup so this is what happened in the
matchup between Sarah Kane and onigiri
they drew all the games and they went
into Armageddon
so circuit has five minutes here Geary
has four but Geary is allowed to draw
and then he wins the matchup so let's
see how the game went a curtain opens
with Knight to f3 the rat is on the
board and before we continue we do have
two very nice photos of this encounter
there you have it a nice close-up of
Geary wearing a not sure if you can
spotted but those are actually chess
pieces on his shirt that is uh it's been
a while since I've seen something this
cool I wish I knew where I could
purchase one shirt such as this one as
its well not only confusing to your
opponents but also very cool and also
here we have a nice close-up of kirkin
there we have it let's just enjoy that
for a minute
not doing anything crazy with his with
his shirt both for us compliments of
Nicky we got the official photographer
of the feeder Grand Prix I will put
links to her Twitter and Instagram a
profile in the description below so feel
free to check out her other work if you
are interested so the 5 by giri
we have III Knight to f6 c4 and c6 sorry
about that
nuts d4 I said c4 sorry c4 and c6 and
with d4 we transpose into the Slav
defense with Bishop to f5 by Geary
Knight to c3 and now II six now that the
bishop is out of his cage you are
allowed to close up the position like
this but now white is able to hunt the
bishop down so nice to h4 Cara King goes
after Gary's light square bishop and now
you could go Bishop g6 Bishop
for you could go Bishop g4 Bishop g4
runs into pretty much the same thing
that's happened in the game because
you'll just move the Queen attack the b7
pawn and here you'll go Queen b6 offer
trade f3 Bishop will go back h5 g4 and
after Bishop goes here white will be
able to capture it and then decide
whether you will or will not straight
Queens if you go Bishop to g6 then you
can capture the bishop immediately in
the game we we saw Bishop to e4 Kerrigan
just pushes the bishop back with f3
Bishop the g6 and now Queen to b3 just a
nice developing move attacking the b7
pawn here a Giri doesn't defend with
Queen b6 rather Queen to c7 the b7 point
is defended and there's no danger in
losing anything in the center because
the center is nicely nicely protected
Bishop to d2 by kurakin Bishop to e7
preparing to castle and now g3 with
ideas of maybe bringing the knight back
into the game this way but also if you
need you can always just capture on g6
the tension goes in White's favor Knight
B to d7 developing and now rook to C 1
preparing to open up the C file and as
the rock occupies the same file as the
Queen the tactics should work in white
favor so giri B beats Carrick into the
capture D captures in c4 Bishop captures
on c4 and here we have castles if you go
B 5 B 5 you don't want to do this since
we said that the rook occupies the same
file as the Queen wise can just give up
the hunt apiece for two pawns here and
after the Queen moves you will just have
night c7 check and win the game for
example the King will move King f8
Knight captures you cannot trade Queens
because the knight would have an escape
square so Queen captures and I just
Castle and white will have a much better
game here so after Bishop captures on c4
with castles by Gary castles by kurakin
and now II five by black and here it's
very interesting hard to say if Kirk in
the knew of this game before playing
this Armageddon game but uh nigiri
already had this position in 2017 in the
tata steel tournament against tirado's
Lavoie taschek where what a shock played
d5 in that game and
in a draw so probably I mean it's hard
to say was a kirkin aware of this game
but he goes for a different line he
plays in night captures on g6 and this
is now a new mood this position has
never happened before and of course as
of no 14 we have a completely new game H
capture son g6 and now Queen to c2 hurry
manoeuvring already with a threat Queen
captures in g6 is the threat as the F
pawn is pinned so a Giri doesn't allow
him to react with a capture some before
now you have to react as your knight
here is under attack he captures on d4
and now Knights to b6 again you cannot
capture because you lose the bishop on
c4 so better back to b3 and now Queen to
d7 again you cannot capture if you
capture here then Queen captures on d4
with Czech threatens to window bishop
and even after you block okay the bishop
is defended Bishop to c5 now threatening
to win the rook and after Bishop a1 now
you get Queen to e3 with an attack on
the rook and after the rook moves or you
defended which is well probably you're
gonna defend it now you get Queen
captures on f3 and it's actually black
who is enjoying the pins and black will
not win material here and the game so
after Queen d7 you still don't have a
chance to capture here Bishop to e3 just
defending the d4 pawn and now Knight
beat the five giri closest of this
diagonal with Bishop to g5 by Carquinez
his bishop on e3 is under attack rook F
e8 and now rook C back to d1 again
putting the rook on the same file as the
Queen nights after Sun c3b captures and
now this Knight comes to d5 here Gary
offers more trades and he wants to trade
down into a favorable endgame for him
because this is Armageddon and any draw
means that Geary wins the matchup
so of course kuraki not interested in a
Rob Bishop back to d2 and now b5 gear is
now happy with his position and what
he's achieved he now is ready to expand
on the Queen side well grouped everyone
by kirkin and now Bishop to d6 offering
a rope trade so how can how can Kirk can
avoid more trades and improve his
position at the same time he plays rook
to e4 which is an excellent move
threatening rook to e1 to completely
dominate the e-file and black really
can't capture if you capture not only
this white get a monster upon center
here but also after the knight moves you
get E 5 in the bishop is under attack
and once you move it now Queen captures
and g6 works and black will just lose
this game very quickly
so after rookie 4 with f5 by giri a
significant weakening of the King side
but then again you are now forcing
White's to either move back to e1 or
capture on e8 so a carbine captures with
rook captures rook captures an e 8 now
getting the other look into the game and
now c4 of course you want to open up the
position and free or light square bishop
here you have to capture it if you don't
capture it then white just wins material
for example if you play 93 then just
captures captures and c5 check wins the
bishop on d6 it's a game over so but
should capture be captures on c4 with
Queen captures on c4 and now of course
the giri wants to unpin he plays King to
h7 now the knight can move but now
Kerrigan transfers his attention to the
isolated weak C pawn here so Bishop to a
4 how do you defend it and it's not easy
to defend it but but the best idea is
just rugby 8 it's a hard move to find
especially in an Armageddon game for
example you give up the c6 pawn and then
Knight b6 you offer to trade Queens of
course white will probably decline as it
is in Armageddon let's say Queen c2
Queen c7 and now you're down upon but
you're still playing the game here after
Bishop a4 giri played Knights the e7
defending the c6 pawn but now it just
doesn't work here at Kerrigan has a
winning position and feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the
winning move for a kurakin while I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent winner of
Armageddon games and for those who if
you just want to enjoy the show
d5 is the winning move here d5 wins
because you cannot trade if you trade
then just not even captures and captures
but rather Queen to h4 check [ __ ]
moves and you win the Queen for nothing
or if after d5 black decides to capture
with the knight then just
of captors here you win material or not
even that you can just capture with the
queen is enough just you will win even
more material Europe a piece in a
completely winning endgame
so after d5 giri now decides okay it's
time to defend the CC pawn one more time
we have looked the c8 but now D captures
in c6 of course you have to capture with
the night if you don't want to suffer
material loss knife captures on c6 and
now Queen to h4 check and now you will
see the the true power of the bishop
pair there is only one move for the
black king that's King to g8 now how do
you continue the attack of course now
you just start using the bishop pair
Bishop to b3 check
you cannot oppose the bishop nothing can
block the bishop you can play Queen to
f7 but that's just silly
so King to f8 was played now comes Queen
288 with check King to e7 and now once
again feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning move for white
I'm of course only only kidding of
course you'll see it it's mating one
Bishop to g5 delivers checkmate this is
what Kerrigan played and this is how
onigiri was eliminated from the riga
Fida grand prix 2019 so really an insane
matchup to classical games Rondon to
rapid games wrong to other rapid games
run the shorter ones then to blitz games
row became is wrong and then at this
game in armageddon really just a beauty
bishops slicing the board in half queen
controlling the last rank and the black
king is just doomed here yeah that's
what happens those are the joys of
armageddon for the audience probably not
for the players all that much but even
in a normal chess where we really saw
armageddon for the first time in such
you know with such elite players playing
it
everyone favors white even though white
has to win everyone favors white this is
something i thought will not be the case
in Armageddon I thought you know black
will always be able to draw a normal
game but not really white wins
armageddon so it's really really awesome
but yeah that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it we're gonna show at least one
more game from round 1 and from the
tiebreaks and then we're gonna check out
the standings and who you know
when will goes into the quarterfinals
and who goes home I would like to thank
mikaël Cabral Frank combs and the
Michael ml schinsky for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous video Sarah thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content continuing this short coverage
of the feed a Grand Prix checking up on
your suggestions and of course
continuing the capablanca saga thank you
all I will soon have an excellent start
of your week